[Music]
see ready break here you're standing in
for another line so we can't gain the
drill so you have to clear
your game so this is pulling out of my
fridge so that you can't control my
Center you're breaking a base breathing
[Music]
it's a lot of weight let's look at that
for a second look right there here is
all my weight and you're going to try to
push it back and if you could push you
back you're giving me back my balance
but that's a lot of weight that's not
good form
we don't earn here right we make a
circle with the head you want it out
again you see there's no way I can hold
that
so that must be a mistake got it
so you go out get out of it and here
what did you have controlling work
within my grips again this this angle
how in the world could I keep that I do
you want me to go like this like this
pace where I'm just walking
nothing's allowing me to do that and
again let's do that one and you're on
the line again right and now if you're
more strong enough
not a nothing
your hands are tied not yet
[Music]
so where's our gonna pull me okay
that's how Marshalls that so again I'm
going that way and you're like no I'm
gonna do that well again that's a lot of
energy for someone who's going off
balance right so when you go if you
could then you just gave you tackle it
down that's not quite so here to read
you guys our yeah other leg is up put
the other leg up in ving uhr halfway you
just give them back it's now easy me
have this leg no you do whatever all
with all the job to do don't worry
[Music]
No
I have debates about this then what do
you need to do to have an intern
you need a lot of facts right and your
facts have to be accurate right okay
well this is this exchange is like a
debate so right here you don't have an
Aikido fact so if you look face this way
see this this elbow here cannot support
a Jew cook you level cannot support then
you're pushing on me you see how you're
pushing on me so but you have a
mechanical weakness but you also just
have a physiological weakness I think
I'm stronger than you push push
[Music]
so this combination of bad Aikido fact
mechana boo weakness physiological
weakness this is you started this
history debate and he said the earth to
squat you get it that's what you did
that's what you did here let's go let's
look here stay there this foot angle
this is a bracing angle you see that
this leg the knees don't bend you see
this is very bad
so that gives to you she talked about
here where this take your line away now
stay there let's take that away
look what I'm pushing let's extend it I
just pushed I'm pushing into here she
talked watch don't move watch you see
there it is again there's the base again
okay good not bad but now you're doing
it again
you trying to come in but you have a
physiological weakness do you get it
like we could be here all day and I can
stop you from doing yet another bad
Aikido your breathing is terrible
right now
Bayan Aikido facts your arches role in
bad Aikido your hand is now
collapse you see that so the body is off
put it back where it is you see you see
I can touch you now when I'm out here I
could talk to Doherty you see okay so in
all your movement you can touch your
hand come here because that means my
body got here
okay and this is where the grappling is
All Stars this is the wrong arm
positioning
[Music]
so good idea perky mimosa bad idea for G
was
[Music]
you're Santa you're here mmm
right I'm here look look just look at
you're here
[Music]
yeah you follow
these are on counter see how you're
turning that's the counter
[Music]
she's fine for Jiwon that
time to recognize a returning like that
that's fine if you wanted
now you can
[Music]
you don't have your ID no facts Hey
and that's the closest thing you have to
that is - the title like is controlling
the head very similar only that it has
the capacity to project and this does
mean this is going in high-tech knock it
can go out you see and then you have the
hit okay this also it's not stopping
right the attack wall a single leg the
double leg okay
you're just Josh they tighten it on you
touch this you see there is the weapon
it is between them
[Music]
so at a certain point that you chants
gonna try to get their balance everyone
s it wouldn't the best you get they do
that okay and that's what you need
alright at some point they're holding up
its right there's a split second and
that's what I left oh it's just the same
tippy we're just going faster but I'm
alright there you get caught up on this
part and you're not paying attention to
this part right so you're feeling at
home there it is with them you can take
away the top part well writing it right
there it was learn to take things away
dumb exaggerating my taken away
sometimes it's enough in your you can
leave your hand there right and I'm just
going to relax it and it said not to
start a movement so here we are they
lean on me okay and then I'll just relax
my arm and you see it starts to those
little micro things boom it's what makes
your effort your art effortless okay so
if my hand goes here like this hand goes
here did the other hand pull much easier
[Music]
one right here and I'll go ahead right
and play like that right sophisticate
[Music]
try to turn and just high step out if
you try to go backwards that's what you
want
I have turned and I sit up
don't let the other hand go for no
reason
watch how you push your knee over your
ear little I met with the foot does not
go past your toes go inside your click
phrase outside your foot frame it never
goes past your toes
[Music]
always to stomping on the head stomp -
said he deflects your leg it's not use
your tactical self assessment ok don't
enter into a ground fight with everybody
that's got 60 pounds in the same amount
experience
[Music]
we have some parameters for the drill do
you understand that it is being
controlled but you know this is a phrase
you hear in training all the time you're
gaming the drill you're milking to drill
you're letting the rules do most of what
you should be doing do you get that so
if I stand in like this right then I'm
gaming it that she's being told just
keep energy going not let go of the
ground punch me in the face draw a knife
full of God you get it too you have to
be in a place right so would when we're
in this position now you see I can do
stuff to every one of those things that
she wants to do but when I'm here like
this I can the reaction cycle is going
to be too slow you got it
your arch is caved in
[Music]
look for that need rope
that's the kind of game you're milking